En este video vamos a aprender un poco sobre
números pares y números impares. Los números
pares son los que pueden dividirse en dos grupos
iguales y los números impares son números que no
se pueden dividir en dos grupos iguales. Con esa
comprensión de números pares y números impares,
echemos un vistazo a estos animales y pensemos
si tenemos un número par o impar en cada uno de
estos grupos de animales. Así que comencemos con
estas tortugas. ¿Tenemos un número par de tortugas
o un número impar? Pausen este video y traten de
resolverlo. Bien, veamos si podemos dividir este
número de tortugas en dos grupos iguales. Parece
que si tuviéramos que dividirlo, simplemente
así tendríamos dos grupos de cuatro, así que
parece que el 8 -que es el número de tortugas
que tenemos- es un número par. ¿Por qué? Porque
podemos dividirlo en dos grupos de cuatro. Ahora,
¿qué pasa con los pingüinos que tenemos aquí?
Tenemos dos pingüinos. ¿El número 2 es un número
par o un número impar? Bueno, como dijimos hace
un momento, para que sea un número par tenemos que
poder dividirlo en dos grupos iguales, y podemos
hacer eso así, podemos tener dos grupos iguales
de un pingüino cada uno. Dos también es un número
par. Veamos estos castores que tenemos aquí. Tengo
cinco castores: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. ¿El 5 es un número
par o un número impar? Pausen el video y traten
de resolverlo. Muy bien, vamos a ver si podemos
dividir estos 5 castores en dos grupos iguales.
Veamos, tal vez podríamos dividirlos así: ahora
tenemos dos castores aquí y tres castores acá, no
son grupos iguales, tal vez podríamos dividirlos
por aquí; pero ahora tengo tres castores en el
primer grupo y dos en el segundo. En realidad
no podemos dividir esto en dos grupos iguales,
de modo que diremos que el 5 es un número impar:
no podemos dividir estos 5 castores en dos grupos
iguales. Ahora, ¿qué pasa con estas focas que
tenemos aquí? ¿Tenemos un número par o un número
impar de focas? Pausen el video y piensen en esto.
Muy bien, tenemos: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15 focas, ¿entonces el número
15 es un número par o un número impar? Bueno,
tratemos de dividirlo en dos grupos iguales.
Si tratamos de dividir de esta manera,
vemos claramente que los grupos no son iguales,
tenemos más focas en la parte de abajo que en
la parte de arriba: arriba tenemos 6 y abajo
tenemos 9. Tal vez podríamos hacer algo así;
ahora tengo 7 en la parte superior y tengo 8 en
la parte inferior, todavía no son grupos iguales.
¿Y si lo hacemos de esta manera? Ahora tengo 8
en la parte superior y 7 en la parte inferior,
de modo que no importa cuánto lo intentemos
-suponiendo que no podemos cortar una foca-,
no vamos a tener grupos iguales, no se
pueden dividir en dos grupos iguales,
por lo que 15 es un número impar. Ahora,
¿qué pasa con los monos que tenemos aquí?,
¿cuántos monos tenemos? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, 12, 13. ¿El 13 es un número par o impar?
Pausen el video y traten de resolverlo. Muy bien,
vamos a tratar de dividir estos 13 monos en dos
grupos iguales. Podríamos tratar de hacer algo
así: tenemos 6 monos en la parte de arriba y 7
monos en la parte inferior, así que no son grupos
iguales; pero tal vez podríamos hacer algo así:
ahora tenemos 7 monos en la parte superior
y 6 monos en la parte inferior, de modo que
no podemos dividirlo en dos grupos iguales.
Esto nos indica que 13 es un número impar.
Y hemos terminado.